without further Ado why don't we invite
our lovely guest all the way from Japan
director of Shield hero hitoshi hagga
and we also have the kakar producer of
Shield hero Kos
arai
pixie all right and we also have our
lovely interpreter Alice thank you for
being here with us thank you I'm glad
you guys appreciate The Interpreter
obviously you're like I don't understand
everything in Japanese so she plays such
an important role so we're very excited
to have her here all right well we have
our guests here so first I'd like to
have them introduce themselves so
ha
hello
here hi everyone I'm the season 3
director of Rise of the shield
hero
hi my name is Kos anime producer thank
you thank you thank you so much for
being here um first question I want to
ask is uh how's your trip been to New
York so far I heard this is your first
time this is my very first overseas trip
to leave Japan so I'm very happy that
it's New York that is my first
trip I'm alien I'm legal
alien ever since he heard that he's
going to be visiting New York he's had
the song by Sting on replay in his
mind awesome yes I'm I'm a big fan of
Sting as well that's that's
great this is also my first time in New
York City and it's really a pleasure to
meet you at this stage let's give them a
warm welcome to the Big
[Applause]
Apple he really wanted to check out
Central Park so this morning he got
early got up early to have a little
stroll and he saw a little a bunch of
these cute little um squirrels that
reminded him of Ru J so we're going to
go into some more questions here so I
want to ask U with a title like Shield
hero that has multiple Seasons now we're
at season 3 and Source materials to
reference um how do you choose to go
about the composition and the pacing for
this third
season
hi
so one of the most important decisions
to make is where to End season 3 there
was a lot of discussion
heated debates on how far in the story
should we take with season 3 and now
that we've all aligned on a decision of
where how long to take the story that
really gives us the guidepost for the
season and allows us to really find the
best pacing and the speed of
Storytelling we hope as you uh
familiarize yourself with the season
look forward to guessing how far we
might go in the story with season
3 to both arisan and haasan so you know
our heroes Adventures against the spirit
tortoise um there was a lot of
collaboration between naumi and the
vassel holders setting aside their
differences to come together to find
peace right so can fans expect to see
more of this throughout the rest of the
season
haasan so
[Music]
as you heard earlier collaboration and
cooperation is a key feature a key theme
within season 3 and so I hope that um
noomi and the characters have learned
from their failures against the spirit
tortois and really learned that
collaboration cooperation working
together is how they move on to the next
level
from episode one it's been about 40
episodes and the heroes still have not
come together and so that's something
that he's felt has been developing
maturing but really progressing slowly
and so in season three we really hope
that some of those hard work Nomi has
been through will come to
fruition so the next question I have
here is for haasan specifically all
right um and so were there any scenes
between episodes 1 through eight eight
air eight airs next week episode seven
just aired yesterday but uh that you are
especially particular about adapting in
a certain way or we Troublesome to
adapt
everything has been such a challenge we
put our heart and soul into every
episode
[Music]
beginning in episode one already we had
a challenge where we really had to
convey the feeling that
uh the party had traveled a huge
distance over a long duration yet in
real time Clippers they really only had
a very short time to reflect that that
Arc of story and so um that was already
from the very first episode a challenge
and something that they hope that you'll
enjoy their hard uh thinking and
conceptualization of that footage
so season one
so what we hope you saw so far in season
three is how large the world is that now
for me and the characters live in in
season one you really only saw the story
within meral Mark in season 2 they
traveled to a different world and so the
season 3 is the first time you're really
seeing the extent of the world that
naumi is in thank you so much for
that are there any funny stories or cool
stories from the production process that
you'd like to share season one
epis
1 no
so I was in charge of season one episode
5 and episode 13 and um all the
storyboarding was done by me and in both
episodes felo
beats as you
saw consistent theme
there
it really makes me feel like I have a
connection with
Motu it's great now for Aran um as you
have been working on multiple seasons of
Shield hero I want to ask you what has
been your favorite part of working with
KAC Citrus on the on the animation of
season 3 and has anything shifted
between season 2 and three in terms of
your
involvement
what I love the most is how much the
original work is loved respected and
cherished by the production team and so
that sense of a true honest respect for
the original work is what really
highlights some of the discussions and
the collaboration ation that we have in
the production
team so for season three we have a core
team of screen player screenplay focused
meeting but even before we meet as a
core um haasa and his smaller team have
many pre- meetings and bring to us bring
to the core team a spectacularly
thoughtful um detailed concept that
really makes me feel like there is true
love for the content you're
wome amazing well um want to ask was
there anything that shifted though when
working between like these two seasons
Seasons two and three has anything
changed for
you
so one of the things that's really uh
special about season 3 is how much time
has been spent to really dissect the
original work and so every element that
is critical in the original work has
been uh adapted considered thought
through discussed
to see whether it should fit into the
series and how it should really be uh
reflected and animated and so the the
thoughtfulness of the season 3 staff is
really
spectacular for example if he brings up
an episode and says oh what volume was
that from there is a staff member who
says oh that's volume blah page blah
blah and so that's the extent and level
of understanding that the season 3 staff
has
I think one of the most critical methods
processes that we've added is a back and
forth with the original author and so
we've really fully digested the content
internally and then what we do is we
propose it as here is how we'd like to
animate this here is how we'd like to
bring this into our our vision of this
content and we have that discussion that
alignment with the original author and
that really allows for us to have a
vision a shared aligned World Vision
that we can present to
you andan first will you please give a
closing
message
we're right about the middle of season 3
with half of the series left we hope you
continue to watch follow us love us and
talk about
[Applause]
us
thank you so much for being with us
today and hearing our episodes and our
stories um the hero our Shield hero is
just Rising so please continue to follow
our
[Applause]
adventure